- [Presenter] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
We are the paradoxical ape; bipedal,
naked, large brain. Long the master of
fire, tools and language, but still trying
to understand ourselves. Aware that death
is inevitable, yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly. We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive. We shape the
future from our shared understanding of
the past. CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines to exchange
insights on who we are and how we got
here. An exploration made possible by the
generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Charles] We live 'twixt the past and
the future, and we live in the present.
And those of us from Scripps, climate
scientists here, try to use our
understanding of the present climate to
try to answer the third of your questions,
"Where are we going?" at least in the
climate area, and how will those changes
impact us as civilizations. We have
learned what Yogi Berra knew all along;
that prediction is very hard, especially
when it's about the future.
But as I started thinking about this
conference, I understood also that
understanding the past is in this
particular area equally difficult. The
reason is, I think that paleoclimatology
is probably the most difficult branch of
climate science, because you need to know
what modern science is saying about how
the climate works, but you have to use
data that you infer from proxies. So you
need at least two, and usually many more
scientific disciplines to make sense of
the climate in the past. But what we have
learned is that it went through a
tremendous series of changes, in a
different environment, but of a magnitude
and scope and rapidity that I think rivals
what we will have in the future. So the
question is; how did we get here? And how
did our ancestors cope with these huge
changes in climate?
And that is the topic of this symposium,
and Rick has put together an all-star cast
of people who have studied this most
difficult topic. So I have just a couple
of questions about the relationship of the
past to the future. We are ice age
creatures. How did our earliest thinking
ancestors survive their huge climate
change? When we reached the present
interglacial, the climate calmed down, and
we developed agriculture and a more stable
climate, but were we more sensitive to the
smaller changes of climate that have
allowed us thus far to build our
civilization? And so with those questions
in mind, I'm going to start the
conference. I expect to have a great
debate between the past and the future,
and it will be mediated by the present.
♪ [music] ♪